steve coffin here today i'm not going to
talk about polish i'm going to talk
about mark zuckerberg's chinese hello
mark if you're listening
i saw
the video of mark's presentation in
beijing to a group of university
students in chinese 20 minutes i think
he did a great job hats off full marks
covered a lot of ground used some
very difficult words and was perfectly
understandable
however i think where mark can improve
is in his rhythm intonation the music of
the language when you learn a language
the closer you can come to the sort of
intonation the rhythm of the language
the better you're going to pronounce
the better your phrasing is going to be
the better the more fluent you're going
to become
now when i studied chinese 50 years ago
i struggled with the tones like everyone
does because it's difficult to remember
is this particular word third tone
fourth tone and to do that on the fly
while you're speaking it's very
difficult
my teacher gave me a cassette tape
of hobalin who is who was
a leading
seongshong which is these comic
dialogues in chinese
xiangchang performer now i'm going to
put in the description here
description box uh hobalin and a link to
some of his videos on youtube i'm going
to put a link to an article about mark
mark zuckerberg which shows his video in
beijing
i in those days listen to these over and
over and over again even if i only
partly understood i understood some
better than others
it was the music of it that captivated
me and had a major impact on my
pronunciation my control of tones and my
fluency
uh today
i would have the benefit of transcripts
and so mark you can find
uh hobalin or other xiangcheng people in
youtube you can if it's hobalin it's uh
the transcripts i'm sure are available
because it's quite old now out of
copyright i would imagine
import them into link save words and
phrases
listen while reading and then take it
away and listen over and over again in
your car or or elsewhere
it's going to definitely improve your
fluency and and pronunciation
um
so that's just a brief just to say i you
know i don't speak like a young
performer i don't speak like a chinese
person but i'm a lot better than what i
than i was before i was able to get
access to these sanctioned tapes so
that's my recommendation to mark
zuckerberg and it's also something that
has application for all languages if you
can find content that captivates you or
you like the voice or you like the way
the person speaks
you want to listen to that over and over
and over again so that you can actually
so that it starts to resonate because
there is that almost emotional
tie to the language we're trying to
learn
the rhythm the music which which makes
everything better so that's my advice to
mark and and my advice to to those of
you who are studying other languages
thank you for listening bye for now now
i better get back to polish